clap de fin pour le cs il vient à peine
de se terminer j'ai passé trois jours
paca trois jours cette année avoir plein
de choses à aller sur plein de stands
alors vous avez plusieurs espaces vous
avez le elvis et si le convention center
où vous avez tous les gros stands et
puis vous avez le récap à recevoir plein
de trucs super intéressant que je
voulais absolument partager avec vous
donc dans cette vidéo je vous ai fait
une sélection de choses qui m'ont
surprise que j'ai aimé c'est un peu mon
best of du cs 2022 j'espère que ça vous
plaira d'ailleurs dites moi ce que vous
en pensez en bas en commentaire
[Musique]
la série des produits vraiment top chez
high sound vous avez alors là c'est très
sombre à vouloir pas forcément très bien
ces deux-là 8k laser tv c'est pas simple
de se rendre compte comme ça à travers
d'une vidéo youtube je sais bien mais
vous avez la laser tv d'un peu tous les
côtés avec des diagonales de dengue et
regarder au fond là bas vous avez un
format qui est absolument dingo en laser
tv et regardez le matos pour obtenir une
image aussi grande et bien vous avez les
deux éléments laser tv pour mieux
projeter et c'est extrêmement bleu foncé
pas si vous en rendrez bien comme ça
mais de ce que je vois moi l'union en
tout cas c'est c'est sublime regardez ça
me semble fait démonstration de force
avec le micro l'aide on a des images qui
sont bluffantes il ya un côté qui est
très pure alors si c'est sûr optimisé il
n'y a pas d'autres lumières mais c'est
absolument magnifique j'ai hâte de voir
les nouveaux téléviseurs qui vont rêver
en 2022 de samsung au niveau du micro
l'aide mais en tout cas tout ce que je
vois ici ça me plaît beaucoup regardez
ça je vous en ai parlé c'est l'odyssée
ap de samsung à l'esa tout c'est
impressionnant espèce de petite souris à
droite on vient changer le ratio et
après on peut venir le tourner c'est
vraiment vraiment impressionnant je le
montre la démo parce que truc est dingue
en plus vous avez des led de côté donc
ça c'est un truc qui est fou c'est un
prototype il est pas encore sorti on
sait pas que 2 sortira probablement
bientôt bien évidemment mais le truc est
un regard des pauvres l'utiliser comme
vous voulez pour du gaming pour ce que
vous voulez personnellement j'adore et
j'ai vraiment hâte que ça sort et
pourquoi pas le mettre à la maison et
moi ce que vous en pensez parce que moi
fossat vraiment dingue cette techno est
complètement dingue vous prenez
n'importe quelle ville chez vous vous a
posé la techno de vidéos window et ça
vous fait une télé alors le but c'est
pas d'avoir une télé sur toutes les
vitres de votre maison mais si vous
voulez vous pouvez le faire c'est plus
un usage professionnel on va l'utiliser
ici j'imagine pourrait bien airoport
faire de l'affichage pour ça marrant ils
ont d'innovation noah skuza hyper rigolo
avouera avoir c1 du côté du particulier
en tout cas ça me reid comprend mieux
pourquoi le crs évident regardez vous
avez le coc vite qui est là tu peux
aussi vous le voyez bien mais il est là
il monte et descend voilà il est là il
est là regardez-la ici mais là non en
fait c'est un stand qui va par les
maladies infectieuses qui va parler de
la grume si vous avez froid voilà donc
c'est la détection de virus mais ils
nous ont mis des petits kobe dans
l'ouest l'autre se marrer voilà c'est
tout mignon voilà salut toi côté
robotique vous allez avoir le massage
par des robots regardez là vous avez
deux grands robot vous mettez là et ils
viennent de vous faire des petits
massages bon écouter dans l'île et
pourquoi pas mais quand on voit que la
robotique peut aussi venir travailler
sur le bien-être et la santé donc bon
pourquoi pas alors ici on est prêt a
besoin dans l'espace alors je précise
pour faire des colonies en orbite mais
en tout cas on en parle on est là
l'entreprise puisque ce tout session a
space vous l'avez écrit juste ici et là
on vous montrera à quoi ressemblerait
alors je passais une espèce de capsule
ou en tout cas un habitat dans l'espace
avec les différents espaces est ce que
c'est le cas de le dire justement
regardez comment est ce qu'on va pouvoir
vivre là dedans faire de la culture en
apesanteur ramasser ses salades avec des
combinaisons un peu style est bon il
manque un bout du scaphandre a sinon ça
va être compliqué pour respirer mais bon
tant l'idée pourquoi pas donc même si on
n'y est pas tout de suite ce qu'on voit
en tout cas c'est que la conquête
spatiale et bien en marche les projets
sont bien là même si pour l'instant ce
n'est qu'une maquette a priori ça
devrait voler qu'on sait pas quand on
sait pas comment mais sans kracik en
tout cas on voit que les américains et
différentes entreprises privées mettent
vraiment les moyens pour rire regardez
l'europe là
si vous aimez l'espace regarder la
troupe de fous un peu montré trottinette
heures et à y regarder l'espèce de tous
les côtés les finitions sont superbes
même ce cas la barre d'espacé si vous
avez de l'espace 2 partout c'est un pc
d'asus c'est le seul bouc 14x hall est
complètement personnalisable
personnellement j'adore vous en pensez
quoi regardez vous la voyez blanche
evans en l'église comme ça ça change de
couleur le truc est assez impressionnant
c'est complètement dingos assez bien w
qui monta sur le x vous avez même au
niveau des jantes la voyez ça va ça
clignote à sa fin un peu discothèque
c'est marrant mais c'est hyper hyper
hyper bleus font je souhaite qu'on s'en
sortira jamais on s'ajuste une techno
histoire se marrait vous montre un truc
de fou mais c'est vraiment extrêmement
bluffant voyez ça change de couleur de
tous les côtés pour y faire un tour
cette dynamique c'est sympa c'est joli
c'est le français une innovation lenval
modèles ils l'ont fait comme ça c'est la
xflow mais bon c'est une unique slicks
ont attesté ya pas longtemps donc si
vous voulez tout savoir sur la x je vous
renvoie ma vidéo mais bon vous voyez ce
cas là c'est juste bluffant il ya pas
beaucoup de voitures cette année aux crs
mais bon il ya quand même celle là qui
est pas mal petit bugatti pour cela
plaisir en a quand même faut le
reconnaître je vais jamais monté là
dedans mais ce qu'ils veulent me l'a
prêté jeu pas contre mon trac assez
important si ces parts à 303 de français
ce qui fait ça s'appelle tally vous avez
de la lumière sur votre cas c'est
vraiment la sécurité pour les motards
éviter de se planter en vous voyez la
signalisation ça va s'allumer par
rapport au fait vous allez mettre le
clignotant à droite à gauche vous avez
un petit boîtier connecté aux usa les
brancher directement avec des gars vous
avez pas d'options vous avez de la
commande vocale notamment alex a vous
allez avoir le trac il est joint à votre
parcours vos dix doigts c'est vachement
bien dessinés thalys et l'innovation
française pour l'instant c'est un
protocole et partira bientôt sans
marcher parce que ça vraiment cool il
faut faire un petit starter à l'indigo
bientôt donc si vous voulez faire
plaisir à pourquoi pas est ce que le
truc là il va complètement dingue une
simulation de grand huit on se tient on
a les ventilateurs en pleine tronche ça
vivre ça bouge je sais pas si elle va
bien survivre mais en tout cas pour le
coup c c et c'est du vrai réalisme ça
elle lâche pas un lâche pas le lâche pas
je pense que pour le coup ça vient
secouer c'est un truc intéressant dans
le but est que pour être le métavers si
vous avez quelqu'un avec un casque de vr
et vous voyez ces mouvements dans
l'écran et le truc qui est extrêmement
intéressant c'est de se dire ok on a un
casque ok on voit en réalité virtuelle
il a la sensation que tout chez lui
grâce à un retour haptique et ça permet
d'apporter vraiment de la vie en fait
aux différents éléments qu'on va venir
toucher aux éléments clés qu'elle va
venir interagir donc on peut le voir là
au travers de caste ça peut aussi être
pourquoi pas des vêtements pas imaginer
pas mal de choses je trouve que l'idée
pas mal parce qu'avant juste le regard
c'est bien mais si on veut vraiment se
projeter dans un monde virtuel notamment
dans un metaverse eh bien il va bien
falloir un moment pouvoir toucher pour
ressentir et comme ça des gants avec un
touché haptique et bien pourquoi pas
même principe en fait c'est à dire qu'on
va avoir des grands pouvoir interagir
comme si elle était en train de mixer
comme un dj sauf qu'elle le fait dans
l'air parce qu'elle n'a absolument rien
donc elle doit sentir un j'imagine au
bout des doigts et bien l'action
d'appuyer sur un bouton ça apporte
vraiment en immersion on sent ce qu'on
fait et ça pour le coup c'est
intéressant par rapport à juste la
réalité augmentée de l'arrêté virtuel
bête l'ats sa porte vraiment le sens du
toucher en plus et on peut imaginer
plein d'applications comme l'avrion et
dj c'est un peu bullshit même dans
l'idée pourquoi pas et je trouve ça
c'est rigolo alors la boîte qui fait ça
s'appelle billets pts 6 et ils ont un
stand qui pas mal ici au convention
center à las vegas et il ya plein visage
différent mais ça vous dit perspective
c'est intéressant laissez-moi vous monde
en tout cas c'est surprenant là c'est
une chaise fait en partenariat avec
d-box et d-box qu'il a fait en
partenariat avec pfizer qui va bouger
c'est une chaise qui va ravoir de la
vibration haptique donc vous allez avoir
bougé alors là pour l'instant elle bouge
pas trop mais elle va bouger vous allez
ressentir ce qui se passe dans votre jeu
si on vous chouchoute pas ça vous fera
bouger bref il ya plein de vibrations
différentes en fonction des mouvements
des choses qui vont se passer et la
grille tout un ensemble de bureaux du
futur qui sera complètement
personnalisables afin que vous voyez là
vous avez de la charge 15 watts par
induction on va pouvoir avoir les
informations sur son cpu sur son gpu
pour pouvoir venir à modifier un
équaliseur cyan le souhaitent et tout ça
va être complètement personnalisable en
fonction à des besoins si on est gamer
si on est créateur dont je trouvais ça
c'est rigolo je voulais vous le montrer
parce qu'il ya toujours des innovations
rigolotes sur les stands de razer ocs et
là une fois de plus bas ils sont dans
cette dynamique avec cette pièce qui
fait un partenariat avec d-box qui va
bouger de la vibration optique et avec
ce concept de bureau qui est
complètement personnalisable et qui en
plus de ça on va le dire franchement est
super beau autre concept qui est un
petit peu dingue c'est ce masque fait
par un riser où vous allez pouvoir venir
bon bien évidemment respirer filtrer et
compagnie mais vous avez un micro à
l'intérieur qui va vous permettre de
discuter facilement avec d'autres
personnes vous avez bien évidemment les
hier 2 riser il a de la gueule il est
sympa et puis vous avez là je perds la
même chose mais des lunettes qui sont
vraiment intéressante une fois de plus
c'est du concept un signe et razer vous
allez pouvoir a priori je les ai pas
testé mais écouter de la musique parler
bref ça c'est sympa mais ce qui
m'intéresse vraiment c'est ce masque je
trouve qu'il a une gueule absolument
incroyable j'adore étaient ces gens truc
voir comment ça marche a calé derrière
là ça vient se positionner vous avez un
truc incarnait assez confortable par
rapport aux tous les masques qu'on a
donc je trouve ça rigolo j'aime bien ce
que fait réaliser en sont vraiment des
choses très très rigolotes sur ceux de
crs alors effectivement on se dira un
masque on s'en passerait bien mais en ce
moment on a besoin et l'idée de venir
vous proposer un masque plutôt connectés
plutôt sympa et ça c'est cool dans la
série des objets connectés alors je vous
laisse deviner ce que c'est mais je peux
déjà vous dire que c'est un objet qui va
être connecté à un film que vous allez
regarder et qui va régler l'intensité du
mouvement en fonction de ce qu elle a
regardé voilà après je laisse votre
imagination faire le reste et je n'en
dirai pas plus je vous montre innovation
qui est assez intéressante c'est une
boîte américaine qui sait ça c'est un
petit cadenas avec capteur d'empreintes
digitales ou posez votre doigt sa
déverrouille très rapidement ça c'est
vachement bien il ya toute une gamme qui
existe chez eux toujours à un capteur
d'empreintes digitales et vous pouvez
également l'avant sans votre serrure
pour votre maison ou vous déverrouillez
votre maison avec votre capteur
d'empreintes digitales je sais pas s'il
y ça pourrait vous tenter mais sur le
principe tout ça c'est marrant voilà
vous avez tous vu vous savez tous ajouté
partager mon cvs les choses que
j'ignorais encore un peu de contenu qui
va sortir sur le cs ne cessera pas ce
que ça donne un peu le le la le tour la
tonalité de ce qui va arriver sur
l'année 2022 plein de jolies choses je
trouvais ça intéressant j'aurais voulu
voir encore d'autres choses mais on a
fait déjà un crs est déjà bien y aurait
pu y avoir d'autres choses mais à cause
du coc vide est un cms un petit peu
particulier en tout cas j'ai bien aimé
j'étais heureux de partager ce moment
avec vous on va continuer à partager
plein de choses sur les réseaux sur tik
tok donc venez me rejoindre sur les
différents réseaux si ce n'est pas déjà
le cas surtout prenez soin de vous
embrasse fort je vous dis à très bientôt
s
maubeuge
[Musique]